foreign
hey Raymond what's up
hey Dr John how's it going I'm good man
what are you up to
uh nothing much just uh you know waiting
for this call very cool what's up it's
not gonna help
um
I'm calling because I've just been I
think struggling generally but uh I
think that the main area that I've been
kind of focused on at the moment is like
work
um
I kind of was like just you know let go
from kind of the second opportunity in
about a year
and I'm like kind of really trying to
reevaluate
what am I doing what am I supposed to be
doing what happened right so you got
fired for the second time in a year what
happened
it's
like
the the two main things there are um
I've been kind of just like working
through
um ADHD unmedicated and so I think a lot
of the feedback that I've received
um for from both those jobs where
are kind of attention to detail doing
things in a timely manner
um staying on top of tasmic finishing
things uh that I'm supposed to be doing
and um not having that done I think the
other pieces are kind of
I relocated to Denver from the east
coast and so definitely a lot of
feelings are like
loneliness as well and so I think like
um and I know that like
a big part of uh my work history these
last couple years have has been remote
and so I don't think that's like helped
me much yeah
um being remote
um and
being away from kind of my core
Community yeah so I'm I'm an unmedicated
ADHD person too okay and I get all the
things you just said and it's been a 15
to 20 year adventure for me
seeing how far I could get up River if
that makes sense how far I could get up
River to begin to handle these issues
meaning I have to have friends and I
gotta sleep and I got to be really
careful about what I eat and I gotta
exercise I gotta do all these things so
that when I sit down to do work I can be
detail-oriented
and so I've had to it's been it's been
it's been an adventure and I still to
this day if I don't sleep the whole team
will just roll their eyes when I walk in
with a handful of gummy candies they're
like oh here we go they know right
um when I haven't been sleeping and I
haven't been exercising and I haven't
been taking care of myself and my
relationships are but screwed up and
I've been on the road so all I want you
to hear me say you're not broken
and also job loss is a major
psychological event
it's really heavy
and I don't want you to be embarrassed
or ashamed by how dark it all feels
because because it's right it's heavy
right
yeah
um
with the first one I feel like I was
able to take it and start
and um you know
mope around for a weekend and kind of
get right back on it
um you know looking for another
opportunity trying to figure out you
know I felt like I was like on top of
like you know the job on became like the
new job and like I felt like I was just
kind of doing what I need to do pretty
quickly oh you did you gotta you got
another job you got to cross the country
and you moved and you got it it's gonna
be a fresh start and it was all gonna
work out and then they nailed you for
the same thing the last job nailed you
for right
yeah yeah I think right through this one
you know it's been about a month and
like I am not feeling that like drive
that I had the first time to like go
back and do it better here's what this
is here's what this is
this is grief and this is good it's
right
and I don't want you to go back and just
do what you were doing harder and better
okay I want you to reinvent the system
and that feels daunting and scary but
it's actually easier it's smaller it's
smaller tiny little steps and by the way
if you struggled your for a long time
with ADHD you like me have a recurring
narrative like a ticker tape like a like
a stock ticker that runs underneath the
story of your life that just says you're
a loser you're a loser you're a loser
Fair
yeah yeah and so these moments become
confirmation of that story that that lie
that you tell yourself because you're
not a loser man
but you look for places in the world
where you can validate that story and
you got one you got it twice in less
than two years
and one at considerable cost because you
move halfway across the country
the beautiful thing is you can also seek
confirmation of stories that you're not
a loser
through tiny little wins
tiny little winds
okay
so instead of you do need to find a job
and I would recommend not going and
finding trying to find another career
defining moment right now or another
dream job I'd find a job that pays your
bills right this second
yeah and I would love for you to get way
upstream and begin to look for things
like
um look for things like
um where can I exercise
and it might start with I'm just going
to commit to two walks a day
and it might be or I'm going to go to a
local gym and just do 30 minutes that's
it
and I get online in fact stay on the
line and I'll give you any mind pump my
buddies at mind pump any workout program
they have we're gonna start small
and
we're going to get a group that we're
gonna hang out with I'm just going to
commit to hanging out of the group I'm
just going to it's going to be weird and
hard if I'm gonna do it
Dungeons and Dragons chess uh any
whatever it is church group I don't care
one of those weird morning workout
groups where all these dudes meet at the
park and they yell and they're like and
they do push-ups and pull-ups whatever
great do that whatever it is
I'm also going to give you my friend Ken
Coleman's get clear assessment it's
going to be an assessment that's going
to help you maybe an accountant isn't
your future or maybe an insurance
salesman isn't your future
but I promise these same things that
make detail orientation hard
can also be a super power when you're
sitting with a hurting person it can
also be a superpower when you're sitting
with an organization helping them
reimagine something
so it's about you getting all the way
Upstream the last thing I really want
you to do
is get with a counselor in your local
area
and you're going to say I can't afford
that what I'm gonna say is you can't
afford not to
because you've got a history of this
happening and that grief is going to get
real real heavy
and what a counselor is going to do is
they're going to walk alongside you with
a flashlight holding the flashlight out
there
they're going to walk with you
and here's what we're going to do a lot
of little wins begins to reinforce a new
story
that you can do anything
and that you can do the the magic d word
you can be disciplined
slowly but surely over time
or all at the same time really quick
some people are just able to flip a
light switch and they say today this is
over
but hear me say I'm not telling you to
go get another job and you got to crush
it because I'm telling you
I'm telling you you have to create an
ecosystem that lets your body know this
guy's driving and the hyperactivity that
spin up that spin up that spin up
doesn't have to be every second of your
life
because now I've got a reputation
especially when it comes to writing when
it comes to editing I've got a
reputation for being maniacal about
detail
only because I've gone way Upstream to
deal with the other stuff
and I'm going to give you three months
of better help too how about that we're
gonna hook you up Raymond we're gonna
take care of you
and I'm gonna send you my book building
a non-anxious life
all of it everybody gets a pony and a
car and we're giving it all away right
hey I care about you Raymond and I want
you to go be well but I want you to do
it the right way one last thing I don't
have a copy of it but I want you to get
on Amazon and pick up discipline equals
Freedom by Jocko
it's one of the best let's dust yourself
off and stand up and here's what comes
next books available
want you to pick it up and I want you to
read it cover to cover you can read it
one day
you got this Raymond you got this